évidemment nous sommes déçus cela dit on
attend de voir ce que donnera le vote à
l'Assemblée nationale j'ai quand même
bon espoir qu'à l'Assemblée nationale il
y ait des députés macronistes qui soient
pris d'un sursaut républicain et qui
refusent de voter ce texte qui de fait
inscrit la préférence nationale dans la
loi française en contradiction avec tout
ce qu'Emmanuel Macron avait annoncé
quand il est devenu président de la
République face au RN les aler s'en
défendent aussi he de cette question de
la préférence nationale en quoi est-ce
que vous le dites il y a matériellement
pas ambiguïé une préférence nationale
dans les conclusions de cette CMP et ce
texte projetigration il n'y a aucune
espèce d'ambiguïé on le voit en
l'occurrence que prévoit ce texte c'est
que des étrangers en situation régulière
sur le sol français ai besoin d'attendre
5 ans avant de pouvoir toucher des
prestations sociales ça concerne ne
travaille pas s'il ne travaille pas mais
enfin c'est le cas d'un certain nombre
de personnes et qui pour autant n'ont
rien fait de mal qui justifie qu'il ne
puisse pas bénéficier d'APL d'allocation
familiale ou d'allocation de de rentr
rentrée scolaire on peut d'ailleurs
avoir des enfants français qui ont des
parents étrangers et qui de fait se
retrouvent privés d'une allocation de
rentrée scolaire du fait de cette loi
monsieur brossa à la droite dit que
c'est ce que veut l'opinion française
que les sondages veulent disent que les
Français veulent plus voilà des mesures
plus à droite sur ces questions
d'immigration qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez sur cet argument-l c'est
vraiment l'argument de ceux qui n'en ont
pas ça n'est pas un argument de fond
d'ailleurs je note que pendant le
mouvement des retraites les mêmes se
faisent fort d'aller contre l'opinion
publique en expliquant qu'ils étaient
courageux parce qu'ils n'obéissaient pas
au sondage et aujourd'hui les mêmes nous
expliquent qu'il faut faire ce que
disent les sondages j'ajoute d'ailleurs
que si on avait raisonnner comme ça on
n'aurait jamais supprimé la peine de
mort et c'est précisément le courage de
responsable politique parfois d'aller
contre le vent ambiant surtout qu'en ce
moment le vent est plutôt mauvais et
d'avoir le le courage effectivement de
tenir bon sur des principes qui sont des
principes républicains vous avez
commencé à en parler il y a
effectivement des figures de renaissance
des chefs de fil de ce parti des partis
de la macronie comme aussi le président
du groupe modem à l'Assemblée nationale
qui ont annoncé qu'ils vont voter contre
dans 1 heure et 7 minutes lorsque
l'examen arrivera à l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez bon espoir vous avez
fait des calculs vous à gauche sur ce
qui pourrait manquer comme boie à
Renaissance en tout cas je souhaite
ardemment que ce texte soit rejeté ou du
moins si le président de la République
en a conscience qu'il retire ce texte et
qu'il ne le soumette pas qu' ne soit que
ce texte ne soit pas soumis au vote à
l'Assemblée
nationale en tout cas je pense qu'il est
t touours temps de se raviser et que en
l'occurrence qui se passait extrêmement
grave et que ellisabeth bornne va
rentrer dans l'histoire comme la
première ministre qui a fait entrer la
préférence nationale dans la loi
française et ça n'est pas rien et donc
il leur reste encore un peu de temps
pour se raviser et pour mesurer ce
qu'ils sont en train de
[Musique]
faire